revenons-en à cet enthousiasme collectif
voire obsessionnel chez les enfants et
qui envahit les cours d'école la folie
pour les pokémon ces petits personnages
se collectionne et s'échange au point
que certains proviseurs en ont interdit
l'entrée dans les établissements
scolaires un phénomène de société qui
dépasse le cadre de la france et partout
avec cette même frénésie la pokermania
fanni au vernis thierry breton à la
bourse aux pokémon on ne plaisante pas
interdite dans l'ensemble de l'école
depuis un mois les transactions commence
dès 8 heures du matin sur le trottoir
devant la grille chacun doit absolument
collectionner les cent cinquante et une
carte du jeu alors ça rend nerveux parce
que madame propre image et changé une
gare qui vive après il ya de la bagarre
et comme sur tous les marchés du monde
il faut se méfier des petits malins et
un accès de la contrefaçon en a qui a
décapité écoles et c'est de la
contrefaçon
les cartes s'achète par paquets de 25 à
60 francs certaines sont très rares les
acquérir pour terminer sa collection
tourne à l'obsession
les enfants vite fait d'avoir sur eux le
sens à d'autres enfants de cartes
ça génère des histoires
passionnel pour bon nombre d'enfants
parfois avec finalement des
répercussions et compris sur le travail
en place mais les enfants ont des alliés
pour éviter que les cartes soient
confisquées à l'école on les laisse en
lieu sûr
c'est moi qui ai nommé poche et je leur
rends le soir quand il
les parents aussi sont mobilisés et
harcèlent à leur tour les malheureux
libraires en rupture de stock
parler de ça et là il faut que tu
viennes ici ça fait le grand album il y
en a qui passent tous les jours il y en
a qui appelle le matin le midi le soir
c'est ces perpétuels en fait la pénurie
est savamment organisée par les
fabricants pour faire monter les
enchères
rien de mieux que de créer la rareté
tous les économistes vous le diront